When you look at the DMT experience and
you look at its effect on the human mind,
how much have you subscribes to?
The idea that we're looking at is
some sort of a chemical gateway,
chemical gateway to what whatever it is
to whatever that DMT experiences that
this is something that your brain has
the ability to travel to. But I mean,
since we know that the body does
produce this and when we know that it's
possible for people to,
I mean I've never done it,
but I know that people who do Kundalini
Yoga have apparently reported trip,
like experiences that are very similar
to a real DMT flash or the mind has this
ability to do this on its own.
What do you think that that,
is that something worth
considering that this is,
this is some sort of a pathway to a
nearby dimension or to something that's
around us all the time,
but we just don't have access
to with normal neurochemistry
he had it all. There are too many what
ifs or who know. I mean there's, you know,
there's so much in what you've
said where you have to go back and,
and unpack all of these things.
When we got excited about DMT,
Terence and me and the
early in the late sixties,
what led us to go to La Chorrera was that
it seemed like a completely different
order of magnitude than any
of the other psychedelics.
And we came to it really from a childhood
that was steeped in science fiction.
So we carried with a theater with us.
The idea,
this really is another dimension and it
may be a portal to another dimension.
And as science fiction nuts,
we were totally okay with that.
And we thought baby DMT
was, and maybe it is, but,
or it's,
it,
it somehow pulls the curtain back on
something that's around us all the time
that we don't see. Um, but again,
in thinking about these things,
is it something that is entirely within
the brain that it originates or is it
something that,
is it like a lens that you know,
or our eyes are covered with, with, uh,
with filters and DMT temporarily
removes those filters?
I think it's hard to know. I mean, I
think maybe experimentally we could,
we could begin to approach
this. Have you, you know, and I,
I think we really know. I think that's
another thing about natural philosophy.
Um,
that's important that science is
overlooking and natural philosophy always
remembers the limits of what is known.
You know,
and science is a bit arrogant about
what they think is known. You know,
they only in science only understands a
small fraction of all there is to know.
And I was another psychedelic
always remind me of this,
you know, when I take it,
remember the limitations of your knowledge
or sometimes more or less kindly says
it, right? You don't know shit.
And it's true. We don't know shit.
You know, and sciences
can forget that, you know,
but as far as this DMT a thing,
you know,
this is actually a, there's
controversy about this because, uh,
you know, um, a lot of it,
a lot of people who have
worked in this area say it's,
it's pretty well established that
endogenous DMT can produce these states,
that the pineal can secrete DMT under
certain circumstances or under stress.
The lungs can produce large amounts of
DMT that are translocated to the brain.
Um, but it's, it's not so clear
that that goes on. I mean,
it's clear that it can be produced.
But David Nichols, you know,
who knows a thing or two
about pharmacology, it,
founder of the Heffter institute worlds,
you know,
most,
uh,
authoritative highest authority when it
comes to the chemistry and pharmacology
of, of psychedelics. He's the redeemer.
He's taken a reductionist argument
on this that's Kinda hard to,
uh,
to knock down,
which is that DMT is
produced in dodgy honestly,
but it's chopped up so quickly that
it never reaches the site of action.
And it never reaches the levels at the
neuron that it would take to activate the
neuron. Um, you know,
so want to consume or are you saying
endogenously produced the MTN endogenously
so that it, it does, when you consume it,
obviously you flood the system and you'll
get much higher levels than has ever
produced indogenous Lee and I,
but we haven't really measured the
levels produced in dodgy honestly,
during especially these extreme states.
And that's part of the problem.
That's part of the problem. How do you do
that? Have you done, how do you do that?
What have you done Kundalini and tried
to recreate? No, I haven't either.
I've been, you know, Terence had that
fantastic joke. Uh, it was, uh, uh,
talk about, uh, that this
monk had PR practice,
the city of levitation. Do
you remember this one? And uh,
that the Buddha came to town and he said
for the last 20 years I practiced the
city of levitation. I can now walk on
water. And the Buddhist said, yeah,
but the ferries only a nickel.
It's like, do you want to practice
Kundalini for 10 years? And,
and Bang your head towards the East
or just smoked DMT 30 seconds later.
Right in the center of the universe.
But I think the last time I was on
your show, we talked about this, uh,
this other thing, this Algina
light we discussed. Yes.
And I don't know if you've interviewed.
Yeah, we have to buy you one.
I said we were, we've totally dropped the
ball on that. You don't have to buy. No,
we do have to buy. You want
water by herself. What?
I'm going to buy myself one venue
and this time we're going to do it.
We said we're good. I do too many
podcasts. I forget everything. I know. I,
I've never bought the agile alliance
is interesting because you know,
I mean he claims and that was the
conversation we had. He claims yes,
this stimulates in dacha synthesis
of writing this down right now. Put,
spell it out for me. A Jay and the AE, uh,
ODG,
no light.
And his website is [inaudible] dot com
and there's some good PDFs on there
that'll explain what this is about on that
Jamie.
Yeah.
And now it's quite a big time cause
I just mentioned this guy show.
Right. But anyway, he,
this light can produce some
sort of a side note experience.
He claims it stimulates DMT
synthesis in the pineal.
When you lie underneath that,
it's just a bunch of, it's,
it looks like a floor lamp,
you know,
with a rectangular mount
bunch of LEDs underneath it,
which he programs with an
iPad and different patterns.
You lie under it and you,
it stimulates hypnagogic hallucinations
looking at them that are a lot like uh,
that guy looks like an old school
freak. Look at him. He's a zen monk.
I bet he is. Amongst other things.
He used to be an apple engineer.
He was real jobs right hand man
when whilst he went the right way,
he went the right way.
So he's got this thing.
Is that cord going down to her head
and a hard time seeing what's happening
cause something's wrapped around her head.
That better not be a crystal.
I think that run out of this room.
No, I think it's a deceptive thing.
He didn't attach anything to meet
prospective issue court going, okay.
I said,
so you lie under this thing.
And first time I lied under it, I
thought I got all these colors. I go,
all these hypnagogic affects, you
know, and nice patterns and all that.
Like a sub threshold DMT
experience. And I said, well,
you know, the uh, the LEDs
are all changing color, right?
And that's how I see it. He
says, no, they're white. The
colors are coming from you.
You're so fine. The colors. So, okay,
so it was interesting.
And then we got into the conversation.
How do you know this is stimulating DMT?
How do you know that's the effect?
Turns out it's not so
easy to nail that down.
You know, because the empty is saw a
femoral in the system. You can't, uh,
take urine samples or cerebral
spinal fluid or anything.
It would be gone by the time
you, you did it. So the only way,
well maybe not the only way,
but one way you could do it is you
could do something called a, um,
it's essentially you couldn't do
this to a human because you couldn't,
you couldn't get an FDA approval for it,
but you could put a micro capillary
tube right next to the pineal that will
absorb things as they are released.
And then you could recover that and say,
you know,
levels of DMT or why couldn't you
do that to a voluntary participant?
Voluntary or not? You'd be
screwing their brain up. Well, no,
not necessarily, but you'd have a hard
time getting permission. There might be,
you could do it to a rat though.
You could do it to her. Well,
that's what cottonwood
research foundation's done,
right? They've done that.
That's how they discovered
DMT in the pineal, um, yeah,
to a live rat. Yeah. Yeah. That's how they
discovered it. That was the first proof.
Right? That was the first
proof. Nick Cozy, um,
who's a pharmacologist at the
University of Wisconsin at Madison.
He was really the first one
to show that DMT is a, uh,
you know,
endogenously produced.
Now that's a sigma one agonist as well
as a Serotonin agonist, which is another,
another receptor. Um, you know,
lap. That's definitely that.
But it's not clear what the function is.
It's,
it's a complicated issue, you
know. Um, to figure this out,
I'll send you a paper that Nicole's
rotor elite l linked to a video where he
discusses this and it's like,
you know,
he gave that at the breaking convention
conference last summer that I was at and
it was like,
you know,
he was like the Big Downer
of the conference stride
because everybody has this
romantic idea and he comes along
and just squashes it, you know,
and it's like, man, here, you know,
you have disappointed a lot of people,
but on the other hand, reality is
good. You know, facts are good.
What guy did do that?
Uh,
that sort of made me think,
made me think maybe there is
something to it. He's tried, um,
pre dosing with an Mao inhibitor.
Just,
just take banisteriopsis tea without them.
The admixture about 30 minutes before
going under the light, and then the,
it's much more intense and it's much
more prolonged. You've done this.
I haven't done it. Um, but he claims
that on other people say that it,
it definitely enhances the,
so that would indicate that the
breakdown of DMT has been inhibited.
Is he claiming that you could reach
actual DNT states with this device upon
practice?
Yeah.